how's it going reject nation so uh we're
gonna watch today from emergency awesome
black panther 2 movie after chadwick
boseman marvel phase 4. i know there
have been many statements that have been
issued
since the passing of chadwick boseman
didn't really want to talk about this
for a little while but i feel okay
talking about it right now just at least
see what some of the updates
are i think they were supposed to start
filming this in february so i'm curious
to see
with all the new information that's come
out since then what
maybe some of the steps moving forward
might potentially be
let's talk about it
on your left
so when they needed us
i was watching like audience reaction
videos of uh
like they have these compilations on
youtube or like crowd reactions in
theaters when this scene happened
i'll like i'll never forget the first
time you saw that
welcome back everyone i've gotten a lot
of requests to do new video for marvel
and black panther i wanted to wait a
little while to talk about the future of
the black panther movies in black
panther 2 after it had been announced
that chadwick boseman passed away just
to pay him the proper respect and honor
his life
i posted a couple tribute videos and a
lot of you had been asking me black
panther 2 questions what marvel was
going to do given how surprised and
shocked
everyone was with what happened so i'll
explain
what they're doing right now and on the
other side of that i'll explain why
not going to do that because there's
been all kinds of speculation in the
past week just given how serious this
has all been
may he rest in power but the black
panther character in the black panther
franchise was
very important to chadwick bosemans in
real life so i'll address how marvel is
going to handle that going forward
but the big stuff if you didn't hear the
news last week ryan coogler the director
of the black panther movies
and someone who was personally very
close to chadwick boseman
and kevin feige both issued very
respectful very touching statements
honoring chadwick boseman's life and
accomplishment i've read
he's fantastic in everything that he
does so be sure to check those out
he's played many iconic fictional and
real world historical heroes
but while they were doing that last week
they also revealed that they personally
did not know about his condition
he had chosen to keep that so surprising
people he had worked with the past
couple of years so surprisingly
he'd been diagnosed with stage 3 cancer
in 2016
that was around the time the captain
america civil war was happening right
after he had just started to play black
panther
he took it all like a champ he spent all
his time between
all these movies undergoing intensive
cancer treatments and surgeries
and when you re-watch him during the
black panther movie avengers infinity
war avengers end game
he looks amazing you wouldn't think that
anything was wrong with him just to see
him like that
but this past year his condition took a
turn for the worst and he still did
appear in a recent spike lee movie
earlier
this year but when he posted a video of
himself looking extremely thin
it was clear that something was not
right but here's the thing his family
said that even just a week before he
passed away he was
convinced that he was going to beat
cancer and be able to start production
on black panther 2 in the spring next
year
he was convinced that he'd be able to
gain all that weight back and get in
shape and time to start the movie
they said he was so optimistic that it
was going to be another amazing movie
just like the first black panther movie
which is inspiring
so as a result of that though both ryan
coogler who's still
riding black panther too right now and
kevin's people at marvel
didn't have any kind of alternative plan
for black panther 2 in place
they were also expecting chadwick
boseman to come back as t'challa and hit
another home run again for the sequel of
course so one of the first things i saw
a lot of you asking questions about on
my tribute video last week was whether
or not marvel was planning on
canceling the black panther 2 movie and
just not doing it at all
and right now i can say that's not going
to happen for a number of reasons
the first one and probably the biggest
one being the chadwick boseman himself
said that when he first took the role as
black panther
he just thought it'd be a cool character
and he'd enjoy working with marvel just
like he enjoys working with all of his
collaborators on other movies that he
does
at least at first he wasn't really
thinking about what black panther the
character meant to people
all over the world or what it could mean
then when they were getting ready to
release the movie and it turned into
this big cultural phenomenon
it really hit him and he recognized the
deeper meaning behind what they were
doing and how important it was
this is actually a clip of him getting
really choked up talking about it
working with little kids
so we got to meet a lot of these
children who were looking forward to the
black panther movie coming out and it
meant the world to them
throughout our film man i was
communicating with them
um knowing that they were both terminal
and and what they said to me is
their parents said they just they're
trying to hold on
till this movie comes right right
and i
to a certain degree you hear them say
that and you're like
like wow that's
like i gotta get up and i gotta get up
and go to the gym right now
go to work um you know i gotta learn
these lines i gotta work on this
accident
uh you know seeing how devoted
all of my cast mates are and knowing
that that
that that will be something meaningful
to them but it's
to a certain degree it's a humbling
experience because you're like this
can't mean that much
to them you know but seeing how
the world has taken this on seeing how
the movement is how it's taking on a
life of its own i realized that they
anticipated something great and um
i think back now to a kid and just
you know uh waiting for christmas to
come waiting for my birthday
to come waiting for a toy that was going
to
that i was going to get a chance to
experience or a video game
i did live life waiting for those
moments
and so it put me back in the mind of
being a kid
just just to experience those two little
boys
um anticipation of this movie and when i
found out that they
man did none of his cast members know
that's surprising
yeah it means a lot
so watching him get choked up there you
also have to remember that while he was
doing this working with those little
kids who were themselves suffering from
cancer he was also suffering from stage
three cancer
so marvel recognizes how much the black
panther franchise means to everyone and
how much it meant to chadwick boseman
they're not gonna end that chadwick
boseman wouldn't want them to stop
making black panther movies but
everything that they've said
in the rank i think that's fair has been
that they want to be as respectful
as possible and honor his memory the
best way that they can
so that's why marvel is not going to
recast the t'challa
black panther character chadwick boseman
will always be the t'challa
of the mcu the same way that robert
downey jr will always be the tony stark
of the mcu
you probably see where i'm going with
this mantels are passed down in the
comics
wholesale identities are not the
problems
the mantle of black panther in the
throne of wakanda to t'challa's heir
apparent
shuri is the heir apparent also in real
life
marvel just recently made all the black
panther comics where
shuri takes the mantle of black panther
free for download but what is that story
and how do they now wow passing away
t'challa passing away so soon after
avengers end game when they all just
came back
snapped back by the hulk's infinity
gauntlet you don't send a champ
in a king like black panther out with a
couple lines of dialogue it has to be
something epic
it has to have deep ramifications to the
universe and if we're talking about the
mcu
the future marvel movies the other
characters in the other movies like thor
the other surviving avengers have to
feel the weight of it
the two most common ways that you do
this are one with the new big bad which
is the more obvious choice
in one of the more respectful but epic
ways to do that would be to tie it to
the debut of a major new
x-men or fantastic four villain like
neymar or doctor doom that's true
only speculation but t'challa winds up
passing away at the beginning of black
panther two of preceding the events of
the movie
defending wakanda from an attack from
one of these new villains
the second way that you can address his
passing is the avatar the last airbender
way
if you haven't seen that series it's one
of the best series of all time
it's on netflix please go watch it but
after the events of avatar
the last airbender aang wound up having
a family with katara but died
[Music]
but because he'd been stuck in the ice
for a hundred years using the avatar
state to survive
he was really about to remember
the reason why he passed away wasn't
because of the big battle it was just
because of the physical stress
of being in the avatar state for such a
long period of time
shortening his lifespan so if there were
ever an acceptable time to use old
footage of chadwick boseman t'challa
or reworking him to put him back in the
movie it would be to have shuri
speak to him albeit briefly inside the
spirit world
where he spoke to his father king
tachaka after he had passed away
but one of the most important lines of
dialogue that he has in any of the
marvel movies is in captain america
civil war after his father dies
and this is very timely and relevant he
says that death is not the end in their
culture
it's more of a stepping off point but
then what is the actual story of the
black panther 2 movie if shuri is taking
an
hour right and then they have to
fantastic four villain is responsible
for his death
well the basic premise of the movie
would be mostly how shuri and the rest
of the marvel characters
deal with the tragedy of his death and
shuri learning what it means to be the
black panther and what it means to be
queen of wakanda
so you're introducing all this new mcu
x-men
fantastic four canon and you're also
spinning on some of the things that they
did during the first film
with shuri's character and like i said
they've actually just done a version of
this
in another marvel movie if it wasn't
clear shuri in the mcu
is the exact same age as peter parker
spider-man
the same thing just happened to him in
spider-man far from home
he had to deal with the death of iron
man and iron man effectively passed the
mantle to him
via the glasses but everyone let me know
in the comments how do you want marvel
to handle
chadwick boseman's passing during black
panther 2.
and of course there would be i'm really
not sure at the beginning of the end of
the movie
really not sure man the opening credits
were kind of comedic because stanley's
cameos were all very comedic
the one that they would do for chadwick
boseman would be much more serious and
in the tone
of a black panther character everyone be
sure to pay him tribute in the comments
may he rest in power
you can click here for both of my
chadwick postman tribute videos too
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe i'll see you guys
tonight
wow okey dokey
now i'm a little bit confused were they
he wasn't confirming that they would be
for sure passing the mantle right i mean
to me that that makes the most
sense i'm not confirming past the mantle
but were they confirming
that there wouldn't be a recasting for
t'challa they did say that
you know he is our t'challa for this
world and we're gonna retire
that you know identity and pass the
mantle of black panther alone
okay that's that's perfect because i i
didn't actually read kevin feige's
i read all of ryan coogler's so i wasn't
really sure
what was going on what kevin feige and
marvel was actually saying
i really still think they should hold
off on this movie for as
like as long as possible yeah i would
hate
i would absolutely hate if they were
like we still gotta we gotta schedule at
a deadline i mean
we gotta start shooting this by next
year guys we already had something
slated i don't think that's the case
they're gonna go down
i feel like they would be wise enough to
know that we need
a brand new screenplay first off ryan
cooper spent a long time making the
black panther 2
script they were in this video he says
they're supposed to start shooting in
spring
and that's the that's what i heard
beforehand too this is going to be very
sensitive material you have to handle
take as many years as you need to to
make sure you can craft this
please please do not rush this at all
i do think shuri is the best option to
go it seems like it would be the most
natural way to do it i feel like people
would be accepting an
understanding of that and i feel like
people will be in support of it granted
if this was like the black panther 2
while chadwick boseman was still alive i
don't think people would be for it but
everyone who's going to watch this movie
is aware of the circumstances in the
situation
yeah so i think the most natural way for
this story to continue on and i do agree
in this video i do think
chadwick boseman would not want this
franchise to end no especially not after
the
impact it had on culture you know i
think there's a reason why he decided to
keep his battle with cancer
a really private thing almost to the
point where it was a secret
i do think that they should continue it
i feel like that's what chadwick bozeman
would want
and yeah pass along to shuri is just the
most natural transgression you could do
for the franchise yeah i mean it's
literally within the construction of
their society that that would probably
happen and i agree it's like i feel like
people would be on board with that you
know if this
hadn't happened if time were different
you know i feel like people would be on
board with shuri after a few
chadwick boseman outings or something
like that but yeah given the
circumstances
i feel like they could make this an
opportunity to honor him
in a really beautiful way embrace the
circumstances because that's all you can
do and i feel like
marvel often gives me the impression out
of all the movie studios making these
big tentpole
properties they do care about the people
who make them and having
a humanity around everything that they
do take this off the schedule right now
and just let it gracefully develop into
what it needs to develop into because
also everyone's still grieving the last
thing on people's minds should be
cracking the plot for
black panther 2 right now yeah i mean
i'm not even honestly like
this whole thing with like oh how do we
make it more tied in
with the other parts of the franchise
some x-men villains or something like
that while that might coincide a little
bit more with the
comics hey just from like if i just step
outside of myself from the whole thing
of losing chadwick bozeman and all that
i'm not a big fan of that idea
honestly i'm not yeah might be cooler
down the road or something but
especially for black panther too but the
way black
panther one was crafted where all the
relationships
were so personally intertwined with
t'challa yeah that's one of the
beautiful things about
the storytelling of that movie is that
you have a lot of supporting characters
and a lot of them most
of them have a pretty solid deep
connection with t'tala
and arguably i mean i don't think it's
really an argument shuri had it the
strongest with him in terms of a
personal connection passing on a shirt
would be great
i'm actually pretty surprised uh to
learn i don't remember what ryan coogler
said if he if he knew or didn't know but
for like kevin feige for them to not be
made uh
aware of that was actually pretty
surprising stuff to me it seemed like he
really did believe he could beat this
family members would report that like a
week before he passed away that he was
really confident he could beat this
and he it seemed like he carried that
mentality all these years that we've
seen him on screen
in a wide variety of roles black panther
included that makes it really just
extra heartbreak yeah because that's the
thing is i've been sitting here thinking
to myself like okay
maybe you know he had an inner circle of
people who knew dedicated to his career
you might think and i'm not
trying to dog anybody for not but yeah
like i could imagine a world in which he
let them know so that they could film
maybe a couple things and create a
segway it's almost more beautiful yeah
that he just
he just went for it a hundred percent
yeah and
let life take its course i hope nobody
is upset about that it's weird it's like
i can
i was some business person yeah it's
like because i was really surprised to
hear that it's all the more inspiring
that he just yeah
went forward and just you know believes
yeah maybe
i feel like if someone's annoyed they
better be wise enough to
keep their mouth shut yeah yeah yeah
um so it's like they are gonna have to
adjust
for it but i feel like they can pay some
really
beautiful respect as well in doing so
when the time is right
yeah of course they can make black
panther 2 its own thing but also a
tribute to his life and that
property that franchise can take on a
new quality because it is sort of
important in a different way among the
marvel films and that love and that
passion does resonate out of it right
now i feel like we should just give it a
rest
the last thing i'll say is i don't blame
him for keeping this as private as
possible
it's his own personal thing that he had
to deal with first off and b
from what we know about how media works
if this got
out there like the best thing he could
do is just not let it
consume his life in every single area
and if this was like the most public of
information there would constantly be
it would be like it would be the shining
light on chadwick boseman about him like
his identity would be so much associated
with his cancer struggle it would just
be so much
leading up to it we know how the media
works it would be
non-stop where so much of his image
would be
associated with suffering yeah and
having to deal with this and look how
brave you are
he needed to just focus on doing what he
needed to do while he had
time on this earth i think that's
actually really beautiful how he handled
that
the fact that he didn't make that
information be the driving force of his
image in his personal life so that way
he could just do the work and be
remembered for the legacy
of his art and so that he could just
live yeah without yeah
having people even on a personal level i
would imagine cast that sort of paul
because you know once people know they
behave differently
yeah yeah yeah and so yeah like it seems
like in a way he got to live his best
life possible for as long as possible
and that's
very inspiring it's inspiring it's sad
because
obviously a lot of us weren't like prep
for it and i feel
of course even way worse for the the
people who
personally knew the guy who weren't
aware of this you know i can imagine how
devastating this was for them who who
had no way to prepare themselves for
something like this but i'm glad he
chose the path he did to keep this
as private as possible all right guys
well
thanks for being here what do you think
they should do for black panther 2
why not talk about it be respectful in
the comments subscribe click that
notification bell
and uh i do want to give a patreon today
shout out to someone jean jeter he's a
talented creative artist who does a lot
of experimental videos you might have
seen tyrone magnus even react to some of
his videos as well he recently put out
one of his more artistic sort of uh like
mood pieces uh nyc vlog breakup this
time
during covet there's been a lot of
people who have been dealing with a lot
of harsh
breakups lately i think that you know
sometimes people might not want to be
reminded of it but i think
there's this other side in our life
where we want to feel understood or
identify
feel some type of cathartic release i
feel like this video can be
a good video to check out if you know if
you've been through
a breakup or if you're going through one
it could be a something great for you to
identify with
within your heart strings so yeah it's
like when you want to listen to a piece
of music that uh
you know can translate or communicate
your feelings that's kind of what i
associated this video with being like
so you can go check it out there's a
link in the description box thank you
guys so much for being here and thank
you gene for putting this together
love you gene see you guys soon